I think the larger principle on the
reason that America was relatively
successful in establishing its
legitimacy certainly is Eastern
comparison to the Soviet Union at the
beginning of the Cold War was that
America helped to forge a series of
rules for how countries should behave in
in in in in foreign policy that we not
only expected other countries to comply
by but that we complied with ourselves
those rules were not absolute they
didn't mean that every country had equal
power but there was a fundamental
recognition that there were a set of
rules and International Affairs that we
did not simply define ourselves that
other nations had a role in defining and
that if they can strain those other
nations they played some degree
constrained us as well that was what the
building of the United Nations the IMF
what became the World Bank what became
the WTO what NATO what those things were
all about they were based on the
principle at least even though America
was by far the most powerful country in
those institutions the principal at
least that might did not make right that
there were principles that existed above
and beyond the united states that we had
to try sometimes modify our behavior to
comply with i think that the fundamental
thing that's happened in the bush era is
the sense that other people in the rest
of the world believe that while America
still insists that other countries of
adhere to certain rules that we lay out
we no longer ourselves abide by those
set of rules and we no longer ourselves
give other nations any role in defining
the rules that in fact in to constrain
us as well as them and that although we
keep on speaking about these rules as
universal democracy human rights peace
they don't seem universal to other
nations because other nations are
playing the role in defining them to
other nations it seems imperial it seems
as if America is simply saying democracy
and human rights and peace and all these
other nice things are simply whatever
America decides it wants to do
you